here to react Michael Knowles host of
the Michael Knowles show Michael thanks
for being here so this is surprising to
us so 80% of Americans say we're fed up
with PC but yet we live we feel like we
live in this world that's cloaked with
political correctness what does it mean
you know I think I'm almost getting sick
and tired of winning almost not quite
but this is such good news for
Republicans it's a huge problem for
Democrats
I think the straw that broke the camel's
back was transgenderism you know
opposition to PC had been growing for
years fifty-nine percent seventy three
percent now 80 percent I think it's
because it's one thing to tell a guy to
wish someone a happy holiday instead of
Merry Christmas it's another to follow
that guy's daughter into the changing
room at a public pool because men are
women and women are men I think that
reality is finally setting in people
refuse to go along with the lies of PC
anymore this creates a huge problem for
Democrats though because the only people
who are Pro PC according to this poll
are rich over credentialed white people
progressive activists who donate who
volunteer who carry petitions for
Democrats but Democrats rely that
especially on racial minority voters
other people who are especially opposed
to political correctness I think what
this could lead to is a conservative
lead coalition of sane voters who maybe
disagree about net neutrality or
whatever but at least can acknowledge
that men are not women and I think
President Trump is leading the way great
point so it's not just happening here
it's happening all over the world
including the UK you've got big
government that's trying to infringe on
people's rights so whether it's freedom
of speech or a freedom to eat what you
want
apparently there's a thinking that
government should control it all because
they got a calorie cap for pizzas for
burgers I mean this is crazy right I
mean whatever happened to wanting to pig
out in freedom of Pizza freedom
this michael little caesars has 2,250
calories
Pizza Hut 1840 I mean basically it's
kind of hard to have a pizza within the
calorie window that the UK wants 928
what do you think of that all I can
think is thank goodness we separated
from those limeys 200 the government is
not very competent at many things and
making pizza is certainly one of them
but the UK government is doubling down
on this this is the real danger of
socialist health care this is the real
danger that we're seeing with Medicare
for all plans which is that when the
government is running your health care
when it's paying for your health care
that's your tax dollars all of a sudden
it can dictate virtually every aspect of
your life how you behave what you smoke
what you drink and how much pepperoni
you can put on your pizza government
bureaucrat knows pizza they control your
health care then they get to tell you
how to live your life in in in pledge
allegiance to controlling costs and
pretty soon they control every part of
your life I mean that that is how the
nanny state metastasizes itself
that's exactly right I think the GOP in
America conservatives should campaign on
this they should say look at Britain and
get your government hands off my
mozzarella cheese this example of a much
larger problem pepperoni police is
coming
Michael Knowles thank you very much
appreciate it